[Music]
Pokemon let's go Pikachu and let's go
Eevee are more accessible than most
Pokemon games but that doesn't mean
everything in them is obvious if you
haven't played Pokemon in a while or if
you've never played a Pokemon RPG before
there are a few things you should know
before jumping into let's go
[Music]
if you've played previous Pokemon games
you might be used to catching a Pokemon
once just to get it in your pokedex then
battling the rest for experience button
let's go catching tons of the same
Pokemon has its benefits it's a great
way to get experience points for your
whole team and you can transfer the
extras to Professor Oak for candies that
can be used to improve your Pokemon
stats the biggest benefit to catching a
ton of Pokemon though comes from catch
combos to get a combo started just catch
the same species of Pokemon multiple
times in a row as your combo increases
you'll have a greater chance of finding
rare Pokemon even ones you normally
wouldn't find in the wild and the ones
you catch will have better and better
stats high combos can even cause shiny
pokemon to spawn which is never not
exciting
once you've registered 30 different
species of Pokemon in your pokedex head
to the building connecting route 11 to
route 12 go upstairs to find one of
Professor Oak's assistants who will give
you the judge function in your Pokemon
box this allows you to see the base
stats of your Pokemon at a glance these
stats are also called individual values
or IVs and they play a large part in how
well your Pokemon performs in battle as
a bonus your partner Pikachu or Eevee
has perfect IVs as you travel around
Kanto be sure to talk to every NPC a lot
of them say random things but many
others will give you helpful hints items
or even Pokemon you can trade with npcs
in different Pokemon centers to get the
lowland forms of certain Pokemon like
the super tall executor for example
there's even someone in Vermillion City
who will give you a Pokemon that's
exclusive to the other version of the
game and speaking of NPC gifts like in
pokemon yellow npcs and let's go will
give you the three original starters
from red and blue as long as you meet
certain requirements in this case you
have to have caught a certain number of
Pokemon total they can be the same
Pokemon so it's just about quantity get
Bulbasaur in cerulean city after you've
caught 30 pokemon total head to route 24
to get Charmander after you've caught 50
and gets squirtle from Officer Jenny in
Vermillion City once you've caught 60
you can also catch the three starters in
the wild but any Pokemon you get from an
NPC will have good stats automatically
the more Pokemon you catch the more
pokeballs you'll use and pokeballs
aren't cheap luckily there are a few
ways to make a quick buck your best bet
is to sell stuff like nuggets pearls and
start us since their only purpose is to
be sold
there are also NPCs who will give you
items like these ones per day if you're
early in the game a woman in the
northwest corner of pewter city will
give you a big pearl if you watch her
slowpoke for a bit if you're a bit
further along you use strong push on the
block in the wardens house in fuchsia
City to get a nugget from his Diglett in
Pokemon games you can find items and
pokeballs throughout the world but there
are also hidden items strewn about and
they're easy to find if you know where
to look specifically watch Pikachu or
Evie's tail it'll start to wag as you
get closer to a hidden item and when
it's going really fast press a you could
find rare and valuable items this way so
always keep an eye out what are your
best Pokemon beginner tips let us know
in the comments and stay tuned for more
advanced let's go tips
[Music]
you